esta vez queremos encontrar cuánto es
siete enteros y once doceavos menos un
entero y seis doceavos pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar el resultado bien
vamos a trabajar juntos hay un par de
formas para resolverlo la primera es ver
esto como la suma de 7 + 11 doceavos y
después menos 1 y tal vez estemos
tentados a decir más 6 doceavos pero
recordemos que estamos restando no sólo
1 estamos restando 1 y también 6 12
ambos entonces menos 1 menos 6 doceavos
ahora porque es útil verlo de esta forma
bueno porque ahora podemos fijarnos
primero en los números enteros
estos serán 7 menos
11 12 ambos menos 6 12 a vos y nos queda
que 716 más y si tenemos 11 de algo en
este caso 12 ambos y le quitamos 6 de
esos 12 ambos nos quedaremos con sólo
cinco de ellos 5 12 ambos entonces
obtenemos 6 más 5 12 ambos que es lo
mismo que 6 enteros y 5 12 ambos muy
bien ahora entre más practiques esto
incluso podrás resolverlo en tu mente
podrás decir primero observemos las
partes enteras siete menos uno es igual
a seis y después tenemos que 11 12 ambos
menos 6 12 ambos es lo mismo que 5
doceavos y esto nos ocupa mucho menos
espacio otra forma de resolver esto es
reescribir lo
11 12 ambos menos 1 y 6 12 a vos y
primero enfocarnos en la parte
fraccionaria y decir 11 12 ambos menos
612 a vos es 5 12 ambos y 7 menos 16 y
obtenemos de resultado 6 enteros y 512 a
vos
aquí tenemos varias formas distintas de
resolver esta resta pero al final son la
misma idea